a flight between two european capitals
forced to land in another
among the passengers this man roman
protozovich
co-founder of next an opposition media
channel in belarus
he's on a list of individuals accused of
terrorist activities
and was arrested on arrival in the
capital one minute he was a
like trying to negotiate with a steward
but nothing to do but after that
i didn't find him scared or angry or
something like that
he said nothing he just turned to people
and said he was facing the death penalty
flight tracker sites showed this ryanair
flight from athens civilians where he
was living
changed course just two minutes from the
lithuanian border
belarus had flagged a false bomb alert
to force the landing
then scrambled a fighter jet to escort
the plane to minsk
u.s and eu officials have condemned the
move
eu commissioner president ursula van der
leyen called it a hijacking
and said those responsible must be
sanctioned
while nato's chief said it was a serious
and dangerous incident
which required an investigation
lithuania's president has also joined
calls for sanctions
i'm attending the european council
tomorrow and we will no doubt raise this
issue as well
i think it is time to make it clear that
this cannot continue
it's time to stop communicating with the
regime just by making declarations
concrete measures
are needed president alexander
lukashenko claimed victory in an
election last summer
which opponents said was clearly rigged
[Music]
supporters of the opposition staged a
series of unprecedented mass protests
that were violently disrupted
lukashenko is sort of testing the
uh the tolerance of the eu showing uh
that he can get along with even at the
background of a strange relations with
the west
and being under sanctions and
condemnation and his legitimacy is not
recognized by eu
leadership he can still make this
powerful moves
prosecute his opponents even those who
managed to
escape belarus human rights groups say
since
last august around 35 000 people have
been detained
with dozens receiving jail terms
pratasavich is now among them
laura berdamani al jazeera